Welcome back. We have good news and bad news.
The bad news first is that this is the last
lesson in the course. The good news though this is
going to be the most awesome lesson in the course.
>> So to recap what we've learned so far.
>> In lesson one we talked about what
is UX and the difference between UI and UX.
>> In lesson two we talked the user centered
design process and got into personas and use cases.
>> In lesson three, we talked about the mobile
user and talked about different mobile user constraints. Yeah and lesson four
we are going to talk about not about constraints but about the capabilities
that are unlocked by mobile and the amazing things that you can do
on Android to blow your users minds and create amazing five star applications.
>> So Nazmul, everybody wants to know.
>> How do we get closer to making five star apps. That's a good
question. First, we're going to understand the
amazing capabilities that Android platform has to offer.
Then, we're going to imagine how to use these capabilities
to create some really kick ass features for your apps
and through all this we're going to learn that context
is what helps us deliver five star applications to our users.
>> So, Nazmul what do you mean by context? So context
is all about a user and what they're doing in a
physical environment when they're interacting
with your application. Now, before we
get to the details of what context is made up of.
You're probably a web and desktop developer, so
let's talk about the difference between the Android
platform and web and desktop. There's some fundamental
similarities between web/desktop and mobile machines. I mean after
all, they actually collect data from input sources
they process that information and they produce output.
So what are some of the inputs do
you think that are similar between web/desk and Android?
>> Well they both have keyboards and you can enter information that way.
>> And they also
both have pointing devices.
>> And they both have a network connection. Yeah they're a
lot of similarity of input sources but the power of Android
truly lies in the input sources or sensors that are available
in Android that are simply not available on web and desktop.
>> Exactly. One simple example is GPS. So can you name all the other
input sources that are available on Android
that are not available on web and desktop?
[BLANK_AUDIO]